after unveiling an epic sizzle reel for
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker at this
year's d23 Expo Lucasfilm has released
the video to the masses the special look
is all sorts of incredible mostly due to
its final few seconds which gave us the
first official look at Darkrai dressed
in a black hooded robe Rey wields a
double bladed red lightsaber which she
flourishes downward to snap into a
battle ready position her skin appears
far paler than normal and her eyes look
sunken into her head suffice it to say
this isn't the Rey were used to seeing
but what's actually a play here judging
by the close Rey where is and the red
saber one could argue that she has
officially turned to the dark side
joining kylo Ren and the first order
study her face and her posture a bit
more though and you'll see some signs
that suggest dark grey isn't the real
ray dark ray is stiff when she handles
the double bladed saber whereas normally
Rey is Swift when working with her
weapons
additionally dark ray is practically
emotionless her face barely moves a
millimeter which is a typical of Rey's
usually hyper emotive mug so what does
it all mean well there are a few
possibilities this dark ray shown in the
new footage from the rise of Skywalker
could be a clone of the regular Rey one
of several that were created at the time
of raised births considering the rise of
Skywalker will feature a brand new
iteration of stormtroopers the red
armored sit troopers some theorize that
dark Rey and the entire fleet of Sith
troopers are Rey clones this could tie
into the last Jedi during which Rey
entered a cave and saw dozens of copies
of herself the idea goes that these
multiple Ray's weren't just visions they
are real which would help explain why
the Star Wars saga hasn't yet fully
explained Rey's parentage sure kylo
ren's snapped at Rey and told her that
her parents were nobodies who sold her
for drinking money but perhaps the
first-order edge Lord made it up to
upset her maybe just maybe
doesn't have any parents at all because
she's one of a whole bunch of clones
made for the purpose of fighting in the
Galactic war perhaps her sisters are all
evil while raised the sole clone who
malfunctioned and joined the light side
or maybe she's not a clone maybe she had
a twin with race parents having sold her
sister immediately after their births
the abandoned twin might have grown
vengeful and turned to the dark side and
the evil ray we see could be that
scorned sister another theory is that
dark ray isn't real in the slightest and
that what we're seeing in the rise of
skywalker clip is part of a sort of
dream sequence just as luke skywalker
saw himself as his father Darth Vader
while inside the Dagobah cave and the
Empire Strikes Back
Rey could have a similar vision in the
rise of Skywalker facing her biggest
fear in watching herself turned to the
dark side this could give her the push
she needs to continue fighting against
the first order when the temptation to
turn dark grows too strong there are
about a billion possible explanations
for what's going on here and the same
can be said for what looks like an evil
version of c-3po in the newly released
rise of Skywalker footage the protocol
droid known for his etiquette and
intelligence is seen here with glowing
red eyes that's the only physical
attribute of his to suggest that the
upcoming film features a dark c-3po and
while we hate to make sweeping
generalizations and saying that every
character with red eyes is evil there's
evidence to suggest that this could be
the case here things like that in
February 2015 Marvel Comics rolled out a
new Darth Vader series which revealed an
issue number 3 that the heavy breathing
dark Sider had in his entourage droids
that have the same design as c-3po and
r2d2 there's triple zero essentially an
evil version of c-3po from a design
perspective and bt1 and assassin droids
that recalls the design of r2d2 these
robots are battle droids designed to
kill which is a far cry from how helpful
Threepio and r2 generally are
speculation has it that the red eyed
c-3po shown in the rise of skywalker
footage could actually be triple 0 and
that the skywalker who rises in the new
movie
is anakin who may return as a force
ghost with his literal killing machines
in tow
since additional footage from the rise
of skywalker shown at a disney
shareholders meeting in March 2019
reportedly featured kylo Ren opening a
container that holds Darth Vader's
helmet it's not completely out of the
realm of possibility that the villain
formerly known as Anakin Skywalker could
play a part in the upcoming film on the
other hand maybe the explanation for the
evil c-3po is simple perhaps the reason
why the Droid has red eyes during that
scene is because he has had his
personality inadvertently augmented to
be extra aggressive for the sake of
comedy sort of like what happens to
data's emotion chip and Star Trek yes I
hate this all this is to say that many
mysteries still surround the rise of
Skywalker and hardly any concrete
answers are on hand right now writer and
director JJ Abrams could have taken the
film in any number of different
directions making it all the more
difficult to pin down which theories
could be true and which are total BS the
rise of Skywalker will surely answer the
big questions about dark gray in the
potentially dark c-3po but fans will
have to be content with waiting until
the film's release on December 20th to
learn the truth check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]